what you're doing uh same question to
you men find success and the grand prize
is women what is the
grand prize for being a successful woman
freedom and money
because when you have your own career
you obviously make money if you're
successful
money equals freedom so you can do
whatever you want
but to pearl's point let's say you're
that 45 year old woman successful
millionaire
amazing house you know couple cats
running around shout out to the cat
owners out there but would that be
fulfilling if you never got married and
had didn't have kids i don't think that
you can't be
successful
and have a husband or a boyfriend or
whatever i don't think it's either or
you can do both is what you're saying
yeah because i see it right now like me
and my boyfriend we both work literally
24 7. like we work weekends we like we
work all the time but we both work from
home
okay we both go on meetings go into
shoots and whatever whatever he goes do
for his work but we're still there and
we're still enjoying each other and i
what i love that's why i said that what
we appreciate with each other we're both
very ambitious and we talk about work a
lot and we work on projects together so
it's not that he is doing his own thing
and i'm doing my own thing and we don't
even know what's going on in our work
life do you think do you think he
respects you more because you've got a
lot going on yes he said that he he
would never be with a girl who doesn't
who's not driven got it so respect to
him and and have you ever been with a
guy who found you a little much like too
work oriented like you're a little
intimidating have you been with a guy
like that ever i wouldn't say that i was
ever like intimidating
at least nobody told me that but i know
that a lot of guys don't like when a
girl is very vocal about her opinion and
i'm very vocal about my opinion so when
it comes to being submissive
i couldn't do that because that's just
not my personality but that's not my
personality and that's why i left the
comfort of my own home that's why i'm
trying to do my own thing go ahead ellie
so i have a question because you want to
have this very successful career you i
think earlier in the hallway you said
you wanted to be a billionaire yes and
then you're saying that you're pretty
much in an equal partnership so my
question is is your money gonna be both
of yours money or is it just gonna be
your money like how are the how are the
finances gonna break down in that
when because earlier i heard you say
that
you wanted all of your bills paid but
then you're talking about having a car
when did i say that i want my bills paid
it was it was much earlier in the
conversation i would have to go back and
re-watch it did i need my bills paid
oh you said you didn't split it 50-50 no
i meant for dinners oh if you're talking
about equal housework
yes so that was my confusion i was like
is your money going to be both of y'alls
or no no no no
well let's let's talk about that the
money in a relationship
what should you split what should the
man take care of what should the woman
take care of
let's talk about the money like how does
it work in your marriage well he pays
majority of
most of the bills i have a very small
income that i bring in it's supplemental
income but that's mostly because i can
be fulfilled in that i think if i wanted
to make candles and make no money i
think he'd be fine with that but that's
kind of how the breakdown is and he
takes a lot of pride in doing that he's
very happy to protect and provision and
i think a lot of men don't get to have
that opportunity where they could have
that intimate of a relationship with
their wife female partner
and how does that money work in your
marriage because you said your boyfriend
is pretty successful uh did i say
marriage sorry yeah dear relationship
what girl
uh how does it work you guys split rent
you guys split food bills utility bills
does he always pay for dinner
like she's being very open and honest
saying look he makes all the money i'm
here to support him you've been open and
honest saying hey we both make money so
how do the bills break down
uh well we kind of try to see
where we're very open with our finances
so like he knows how much i make i know
how much he makes and then we decide
together what we're gonna spend on what
like he pays the rent so maybe i'm gonna
pay for the car or something so like we
so but he pays the rent yeah
period he pays the rent yeah well the
rent is the biggest expense that someone
will have not necessarily what do you
mean of course it's the biggest expense
no like groceries and the car gets
successful groceries
no i'm i'm not i'm
but the reality is rent or housing is
the biggest expense yeah no he pays the
rent okay
but
being the man in the relationship paying
the rent you're living technically under
his roof does that qualify him to have a
little more say in the relationship or
no no i wouldn't say that because i
don't quantify certain things so like if
he pays the rent but maybe i'm gonna
i don't maybe i'm actually physically
gonna go buy the groceries so i'm going
to put my time and my effort and my
energy into doing something and he's
going to do something else do you do all
like the cooking and cleaning no
we we he's a virgo so he's like
like because he's you know paying the
rent that's really nice does he like
what does he get in return what does he
get in return
he gets a lot in return
okay like what like like i'm going to
keep that i don't know not answered oh
okay what did you mean by that yeah i'm
if a dude was paying my rat like i'd
make sure that every like i would do the
cooking cleaning i would do everything
in the house you're saying if a guy's
paying your rent you're doing everything
yeah free rent what around the youtube
channel though what around the youtube
channel though what do you mean your
youtube channel you really enjoy that
right so i think you would find a way to
fit in your schedule prioritizing your
relationship and while also not
essentially sacrificing all of your
channels yeah i wouldn't i wouldn't just
like do nothing i think you could cook
and clean and still do other things
but i think you guys are miss
hearing what i'm trying to say like if
he pays the rent
okay but let let me give you whatever
let's say the rent is 5k it's not 5k but
let's say it's 5k
maybe i'm gonna spend
2-3 k for something else so it's not
like
tit-for-tat so like he pays rent but
maybe i'm going to spend the same amount
of money for something else so it's more
like 50-50 it's not 50-50 because that's
just not how i was brought up and that's
not how i was raised okay what would you
say it's like 80 20
maybe 70 30. 70 30. okay
is that a fair split
i mean it sounds what what i believe
most women would expect is the 70 30.
they might not say it and i think that
that 70 30 is the new 50 50 because
we're going to downplay the man's money
versus the woman's money if that makes
sense i think this is essentially a
modern relationship and i don't prefer
modern relationships and i think they
have you know their own issues because i
don't think there's that sweet intimacy
that is between a feminine woman and a
masculine man where you just have these
understanding of your roles within the
home but some people want to gender bend
and they want to do their relationships
how they want to do it i know that i if
i had to grow up in that kind of
situation where i didn't see either one
of my parents i don't think i'd be happy
with that
and i want to just say i was in a
relationship before
where i was he was taking care of
everything and i was just like
i still had my thing going on whatever
but like he was in control and i felt
that i i that was just not for me
because i felt very
um like i don't want to hear an argument
like get out of my house like that's not
something i would ever want to hear
so
i would not put myself in that situation
because this just doesn't work for me do
you think it depends on the guy for sure
so like maybe that was just the wrong
guy yeah that's yeah maybe yeah
definitely okay but um you have another
question natalia
um i have a question for coco from ricky
bobby ten dollars freaking bobby ricky
bobby he says coco i can retire you
today
i'm gonna be submissive no
first of all i would never
i'm in a relationship so of him even
asking that
but if you weren't like say you weren't
in a relationship say you are successful
say
um you take care of yourself and and you
do those things and you feel good about
yourself you found who you were um and
you have somebody who says hey like i
want to retire you you know like i don't
want you to work anymore i want you to
be my wife i work because